hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
categories book seven is devoted to what
Aristotle calls the category of relation
and Greek the proce team and one of the
aspects of it that he discusses a
considerable length particularly in
order to try to help us from making
mistakes is what we would call
correlative terms now interestingly
enough the you know the Greek for that
is the ante stressful top this is the
word that we actually get ancestral
thought from and it shows up at other
places in Aristotle's works and you'll
notice that it's not lexically related
to the prosty or any of the other sort
of ways in which Aristotle talks about
this like post at their own or you know
from something to something in this it's
the terms that you know are sort of
opposed but connected to each other and
this is at the very core of this this
particular category because you don't
have relation without having core
relatives or correlation between them
that is of the very nature of
correlative terms or things that who's
being is to be relative so all relatives
like I could hear have core relatives so
anytime that something is predicated in
the category of relation you should
always be able to index it or connect it
to something else and we'll look at some
of the examples that Aristotle uses here
so for example slave and master notice
that that he's not saying human being
and human being necessarily here
although we're going to talk about that
a bit and again if the word slave and
master is throwing you you can always
reformulate it in terms of other human
relations that people have so the flav
is the doulos the servants right and the
master is the despot ace is the word we
get desperate from right to behave like
a slave master and Aristotle says look
if you
we have a slave the slave is the slave
of a master without a master there is no
slave and you might say well wait wait a
second you know an ancient slavery
people were sold at auction you know
Diogenes you know the great cynic
philosopher when he was put on the
auction block said that he you know here
was his pitch whoever buys me is looking
for a master rather than looking for a
slave and you you know you can raise all
sorts of issues like that and yet those
those are all valid in a certain way but
for something to be a slave there has to
be some master somewhere right when when
during the slave market people are
selling and buying each other and
they're trading hands they're going from
one master to another likewise you're
not a master unless you actually have
some some slaves right these are
correlative terms and and again those
who who you know are offended by the
fact that the ancient societies pretty
much across the globe had had chattel
slavery of one form or another just
substitute something else in there so
instead of master and slave think in
terms of teacher and student or parent
and child or any other sort of relation
right you cannot have one side without
having the other if you're your
appearance and you have a child and your
child dies in a certain sense you cease
being a parent of course you can always
talk about you know your deceased child
and the memories that you have of them
but to be a parent means to exist in
relation to a child to be a child means
to exist in relation to a parent even if
that parent again has passed on and no
longer exists let's look at another
example double de Blasio and half hema
suit by the way the word we get
hemisphere from right Hemi sphere so if
you say that something is w have to end
exit to what it is the double of
otherwise it's not really a double you
know so here's a sort of common example
we see people in movies you know idling
up to the bar and the bartender comes
over and they say I'll have a scotch or
I'll have a bourbon and the bartender
says okay buddy and then they say better
make it a double right well double of
what double the amount of quantity of
the sketch double the size of something
else the something else is half in
relation to the double so let's say you
know the other person in crates of a
date and they're drinking a drink and
it's just a regular shop rite of scotch
and they're looking over there and they
say I'm just half what you have you must
have had a terrible day now the terrible
day that's not part of the correlative
but the double and half certainly is
knowledge and the knowable right now the
nimble as such can exist before the
knowledge is head of it aerosoles going
to talk about that it's a little bit
more complex we're doing a separate
discussion of that in a different video
be to go over that but insofar as we're
thinking about in terms of its core
elephants if you have knowledge you
don't have knowledge just by itself
without being connected to knowledge of
what is knowable so if you understand
plumbing for example it's a great skill
to have by the way you understand the
ways in which the pipes you know can be
fitted to each other and how to make
water and you know solids and things
like that flow properly and how to move
things around weird bends in people's
strange houses or apartments the way
that they're there so that's something
knowable if you understand Aristotle's
categories right and you can teach it as
I'm doing here right now that is a
different kind of knowledge and
epistemological
speaking at a kanay as opposed to an
epistemology exists in relation to its
core relative the knowable the episcopus
tone what can be actually known or what
is to be known if you're studying that
kind of knowledge so these are pretty
typical examples of how correlative
terms can be understood in relation to
each other notice that in his discussion
of this topic Aristotle devotes quite a
lot of time to trying to help us to
avoid certain mistakes in speaking and
thinking about these sorts of issues so
we can make mistakes about what actually
is correlative to something else here we
want to look a little bit more carefully
at his discussion so he says at times
the correlation will not manifestly
appear when a mistake has been made and
the core the core Allah itself wrongly
stated so let's take the first example
that he has here bird and wing now
another thing that we need to say is
Aristotle also discusses how the part of
a substance is not actually a relative
term as part of the substance but you
know it's often able to talk about terms
or things in multiple ways so here we
might talk about the wing as being the
wing of the bird and Aristotle says
that's not technically correct that's
not the way we want to think about it
what is wing correlative to wing it's
thing so he goes on and he says if you
call a wing wing of a bird then no
correlation appears wing and bird
are I mean not correlative so he says
you set up the terms wrong in framing
things that way the wrong term was used
at the outset and calling it wing of a
bird for the wing is the wing of a bird
when considered as winged it as
something that is wing it not as bird
because other things could be in the
class of wing it as well so that's kind
of an interesting comparison he says
when the right terms are used the
correlation will forthwith a pure wing
belongs to the wing it of necessity now
this leads him into a discussion he says
sometimes we don't actually have the
right words for it for this and in that
case we need to invent terms if the
language doesn't have the terms that we
need then we need to create names create
terms that we can use for that and if we
do that then we will be better off in
terms of you know not making these kinds
of mistakes so he says let's take the
example of boat and rudder now we of
course do have this term in English
rudder but at the time that Aristotle is
writing in Greek presumably this is not
a term that people would have would have
used so boat and rudder is the rudder
the rudder of the boat of the rudder
exists in relation to the boats you'd be
tempted to say yes but Aristotle goes on
and he says to a boat is inappropriate
and fails to bring out the correlation
fails to bring out how they are related
to each other in this way she says not
indeed to the boat viewed as boat does
the rudder belong of necessity why not
there are some boats that don't have
rubbers right there's there's plenty of
rudderless boats I think is a canoe for
example or you know one of those little
round
what's that that they used to make with
hides and and branches and things like
that I think it's called a course coal
or something along those lines very
treacherous way to travel around a
rowboat doesn't have a rudder you know
lots of boats may fail to have something
like a rudder even take like a motor
boat right that has a motor in the back
you can say well the motor is performing
the function of the rudder being used to
steer yes but it's not a runner alright
so what would be the actual core
relative of the rudder Rutter so the
thing that has a rudder now this is a
weird way of talking even in English
right and so hereís level says this is
where we make up a term boat is that
boat of a rudder as rudder is rudder of
a boat since no proper term exists we
coin one to suit the occasion and speak
with more accuracy thus the rudder is
rudder of the rut gird that's why I have
these things in parentheses here and if
we express ourselves in this way then
the terms he says will be reciprocal
they will be given in given from each
other given in relation to each other
and so he says so in all other cases
ahead will be better defined as
correlative of that which is headed
that's a weird way to talk to you isn't
it so a head is a part of a substance
right my head is part of me Greg Sadler
this individual thing primary substance
air so saying no no we look at the head
in relation to this thing as being
something headed then we have a genuine
correlative and he says animals in a why
do we knows animals simply as animals do
not have heads of necessity so I'm don't
have heads and you know we could talk
about hands that way or tentacles that
way or all sorts of things that way so
you see the idea now the master-slave
thing again he brings up as another
example in this case
this is a very interesting one to think
about it quite rich if we think about
the implications for technology or human
relations but I'm gonna have to skip
that in this video but I'm just putting
that out there he says relatives are
referred to their correlates provided
there rightly to find and I want to say
this because if the coral it happens to
be stated in a casual or inaccurate way
the terms cannot cannot be reciprocal so
let me explain what I mean it says let
slave be defined in relation to human
being here is translating as man but
anthropos can be human being right so
the slave is the slave of a human being
and yes in a certain sense that is
correct you know if we're thinking about
the institution of slavery it is a part
of what we find barbaric an objection
about about it a human being is owned by
another human being a human being is
forced to be the slave the tool the eris
also the unsold tool of another human
being but it's not really accurate in
this sense to say that the slave is the
slave of the human being the claims in
the slave of a master slave exists as a
term as the designation as a concept in
relation to master and vice versa so so
eres level will go on and he says slave
could be defined in relation to human
being or biped or whatnot instead of it
being defined in relation to master and
if this is the case then no correlation
no no correlative connection actually
appears for the reference is really
inaccurate so he says again let us grant
the two things are correlative with one
another and the correct term is being
used for the purpose of stating the
second if we remove all of its other
than that is irrelevant attributes
leaving only that in virtue of which it
was called the correlative then we'll
that said correlative be nonetheless
found to exist so the core relative of
slave
is not human being its master and we
might think this out in terms of like
what what is it to be a slave what is it
to be a master there's clearly a power
relation there there's some sort of
relation of domination of ownership
there's a lot of things that are packed
into this but they don't necessarily
need to imply human being so this is
where I said we have all sort of
interesting rich implications so he says
you know if we remove one we remove the
other if we remove the slaves then
there's no master if we remove the
master then there is no slave now the
last thing that I want to point out here
is that in in many cases correlative as
Aristotle says come into being together
this is not the case in terms of the
knowable or the perceptible in relation
to knowledge or perception Aristotle
says the knowable are perceptible in
generally proceeded the actually knowing
about them you know they exist out in
the world and then we get to know them
and precede them but in the case of all
these other things it is the case that
one comes into relation or one comes
into being in relation with the other
and vice versa now that's not to say
that if you know we've got you know
slave and master who happen to both be
human beings that the human beings
themselves you know may not they outlive
each other or anything like that but
what we're talking about here is not
human being and human being we're
talking about these core relatives slave
and master or teacher and students or
pick whatever else you want to
substitute in there and in those cases
they do come into being as that thing as
as you know we could say the social
roles in this case
at the same time as another likewise
with the double and the half you have a
double precisely because you have a
correlative half and vice versa